[Applause]
with your host tiny tiny chair say hi we
are back with episode number 26 of the
corridor cast it's good to be here I'm
here with guests okay our real names
there are real names should be reenter
this so we don't have people's eardrums
I think people like to have their
eardrums destructs for your I'm Jake
what's your name Sam it's Jake Sam Wren
what's your name what's today
Orbis if you guys are listening only and
we might confuse the resume only you
cannot hear the sound of the waves the
same our opinions will be different
different brains yeah well put these
t-shirts because today's sponsor is not
the corridor digital merch store its
plug in everything that's right guys
we're gonna tell you blent more about
them later but for now let's jump into
our first topic
hey the Boston Dynamics video speaking
of plugins so recently we released a
video called bus I don't even know what
it's called Boston Dynamics robots fight
back yes new robot fights back you know
it was a viral hit it blew up over the
weekend yeah and a lot of people saw it
a lot of news articles were written
about it and it was a big deal for us
talk about that a little bit here having
experience yeah with me and Jake what
was it we were in Portland we were
walking down old let's go all the way
back yeah let's let's roll this all the
way
sound effect episode inception is
basically we had been talking with this
company xns who makes the motion capture
suit
they were like you want to mess with
this you want to get it on loan I said
yes yes yes and then basically we had in
studio we played with it we figured it
out you guys made the Transformers piece
and after seeing how that turned out and
how cool it looked it all kind of put
our heads together and I specifically
remember ujq words like you're like this
is so cool we have to do something else
with it before we give it back and we're
like yeah we do yeah we definitely have
to do that and we put our heads together
we came up with a few ideas that we shot
down but then in a stroke of genius
Clint was like what if it was me and
Jake in Portland and we were like we
were like just riffing on the porch you
know as you do yeah and we were like yo
Boston Dynamics meets the xn suit and
it's the scientists beating up the
robots we had a few other ideas before
that yeah cuz they will do the Amazon
warehouse well yeah but that was the one
that I remember thinking alright this is
a solid idea the idea being that like in
Amazon robot is taking over our jobs
because they Sam sampled at that article
it was like new it's like an Amazon
robot that fires people basically an
algorithm they'll fire people so we're
gonna literal eyes that you have a robot
just like this Boston Dynamics guy roll
rolling around firing people yeah so
funny but yeah it didn't have that magic
touch to it yeah yeah a lot of lot of
stuff needed to come together to shoot
it but yeah this this one kind of
clicked and it's funny because it was
just like a parody at first but who knew
what it would blow up in become then
after the Amazon video we went to
geriatric transformers which I don't
know maybe that's more of a fun idea to
talk about that it is - see I like
Oldsmobiles
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah that one we had a good time riffing
on that but then you know nothing
nothing felt quite right on those ideas
until and we were just walking on the
street and you're like well we could
always go
to the Boston Dynamics idea and then
like what what do you mean go back to it
where did this come from this is this is
the perfect iteration of this concept
yeah so I think the one thing is is that
we didn't actually set out to fool
people with this no no what about to
make the most interesting accurate
parody blossom dynamics that we could
yeah yeah that in fact it was try to
make it as a realistic-looking as
possible but we didn't specifically set
out with the goal of tricking people
into thinking they're watching mainly
cuz we didn't think that was an
achievable goal exactly this is awesome
it's icy hot it looks 100% believable
but in this day and age who I don't know
who sees a video on the internet and
believes it I guess actually the answer
is actually everyone but optimists we
were talking about how like the
difference between people watching it on
the coridor Channel versus people who
saw just the snippet on Twitter or
Instagram
yeah because they didn't see the full
video where we had like hey we're
selling shirts too and like it's just me
goofing off in a green-screen kind of
thing to clarify that basically what had
happened is that for our for everyone
listening watching it who don't know the
our video ended up getting ripped pretty
much immediately and re-uploaded to
every different media platform mainly me
me
my platforms mean platforms you know
like aggregates yeah mainly Twitter was
the main place where the views started
taking off there is one video that ended
up with like 17 million views in two
days in several other videos with
multiple millions of views all on
Twitter from different users re
uploading the video and so when in the
process of re uploading it they chopped
out the whole part at the end where it's
like hey you know check out our
merchandise where it's like obviously
the illusion is broken at this point so
without any of that people are just
scrolling through Twitter and they see
this robot getting abused and then the
video ends and you're like dang it went
crazy and you're like okay that Boston
Dynamics is up to some shady stuff these
days yeah next tweet yeah exactly I
actually even I think the most effective
cut down was the one that starts in the
middle of the test with it like there's
no one walking in the building it's just
boom robots being tested and some of
them that
ended before it actually goes rogue yeah
because of Twitter's like video like
limit some of them were were trimmed to
be Batwoman is yet to yeah 20 seconds on
Twitter so I found that really
interesting because what that started to
do is create this weird illusion that
this could actually be a real video and
no and and and no one read the text in
the bottom we argued about this for so
long it's like do we write Boston I am
dynamics or do we not do this and then
obviously the there was this you know
you were very clear Jake I like it we
can always change the title if we write
Boston Dynamics there but he cannot do
it if it's baked in the video so we
ended up going boss town dynamics yet no
one read it anyways so didn't matter cuz
over they cbos just like people nor like
that just like oh you just don't even
think about it especially if you're
already familiar with Boston Dynamics
yeah cuz you're also staring at a robot
getting kicked and shot in the face with
a gun and stuff like that so it's like
you don't even look at it but other
people is the first thing they see
mm-hmm like I showed a friend she was
like last town dynamics I was like that
was literally the first thing you saw
the one guy who though who was like I
know this wasn't real because you guys
have California plates it obviously
you're not in Boston obviously this is
staged and then yeah yeah that one post
he shared is so funny it's like
obviously this was staged and like no
it's all CG it's like what it was even
just like what it was like I don't think
you're right I'm pretty sure it's not
CGI in that they only staged it yeah
it's like no they just got the role the
old robot out of the closet to do some
training simulations dude one sent me a
message on Instagram that was like I
they had to have been trolling me but it
was like this one guy it was like CEO of
mega core of industries and like hi I'm
an arms dealer and I would like to
purchase this robot that you use I would
like to you know the statistics and
whatnot
we were looking into something like this
for the future thank you goodbye and I
like you find this again so we can look
at this so here's the thing because that
is that was like an absolute joke until
you go to his profile and you're all of
a sudden kind of like hesitating like
wait a minute what is he like actually
serious cuz he actually has a bunch of
posts that are like no if we want to
call it out but I don't don't don't read
the exact name of the guy because but
I'm really curious cuz that's the best
that is fascinating but I'm like you're
you went to a film makers Instagram page
it should be incredibly obvious just by
judging at the other eight posts
surrounding them one this is is this a
sign of the times guys because you you
take something that you like think about
all the layers going on here it's like
okay you've got corridor digital we're a
little studio here in LA we make like
high-end concept videos okay we got this
great motion capture suit which is this
really sort of cutting-edge technology
in the way that it functioned and
allowed us as a small independent studio
to access that technology and take
advantage of it right which isn't
something that traditionally it's always
only been like big movie studios or big
game studios right the equipment is
expensive so that's that's Tier one can
right that's tier 1 and then tier 2 is
let me know you take all this experience
get more the regular audience that we
have the experience we have making these
videos and we post it on to our primary
social media platform corridor digital
on YouTube and it gets this initial
amount of green screens hits and views
and then obviously people with these so
that's Tier two we post it on a platform
that has followers and then people that
have meme compilation platforms like on
Facebook and Instagram well there's all
these meme profiles to your three they
take that they chopped it up right they
don't you know take it out of context
you reduce the resolution of it so
you know and you put it on onto like a
Twitter post so you go from like this 4k
upload I don't know if it was 4k or not
anyway yeah 4k down to like 720 then cut
out cut the heads and tails on it do
just like 60 seconds or 2 minutes upload
that back on to Twitter condenses it
even further well yeah it's the
photocopy effect just like you're
photocopying a photocopy because you're
downloading an h.264 video right we
uploading it it gets reprocessed then
other people are downloading that
alright many people were downloading the
one Russian Twitter video as opposed to
our YouTube videos I'm so downloading
that one so everything's just been like
so now there's no context the cott the
concept is still there like right like
the initial artistic concept that we
went for is still there but now there's
no context you're photocopying the work
and now it's like is this real where did
this come from what is this and I think
that's the interesting element here it's
it's kind of the nature of virality has
changed since we started YouTube whereas
previously the nature of virality was
simply sharing the content directly from
the source like there was certainly
reuploads from time to time but I'd say
like the true original virality was you
create a YouTube video and then you have
a direct link to it because it's easier
to share a URL then just straight-up
download a video and re-upload it on
your own yes my email change that was
the original viral yeah but yeah exactly
yeah but you know you have Facebook you
do on Facebook or you put a youtube link
on Twitter or something like that but
but it's crazy watching this go viral
cuz the last video that truly went viral
for us was the real GTA video yeah sure
and Nico would make an argument for nerf
John wick but I don't think that's
nearly the same sort of caliber is now a
real GT I was totally I mean real GT is
still the most views in one day we've
ever gotten on the video but but um but
it's really interesting because the
thing is there's like a it's kind of
like a little paradox or like catch-22
kind of situation going on here where
it's like we don't want people re
uploading and profiting off of our
content but without that people can't
share it across platforms and it can't
go viral mm-hmm you know cuz yeah
because those other media platforms
literally uh
suppressed
outside links Facebook I know for a fact
does this if you share a faith YouTube
video on Facebook it's not gonna get the
same share ability whereas if you're
just directly upload to Facebook it's
your set because they're not profiting
they're there they're taking people out
of their sight yeah yeah yeah
I mean thankfully I think on Twitter you
can when you throw a youtube link on
there it's still embeds and it still
plays you can on a mobile app so it's
not like but it doesn't autoplay in the
tweet itself and that's the key
difference I guess that is the key
difference but you know it's so they're
always prioritizing their own content
over external links so without without
trying I think we we introduced not
without trying without effort but
without trying to do this end we've
we've we found ourselves in a position
where we we caught a little bit of light
being shed into what it's like to like
create fake news and all these other
kinds of things that are a little bit
more sinister with social media yeah
because you can very easily see how you
can go from like viral video made by a
regular studio regular guys just like us
to somebody being like hey I'm going to
incept this story or this idea into the
universe yeah and with like malicious
intent yeah with malicious intent
understanding that this is how things
work you know someone takes it they
reapply you photocopy effect you were
uploaded to these different platforms
it's not enough context you don't
understand what it is you don't
understand where the source material
came from and all this sudden there's
there's a piece of information out there
but I think yeah and it's funny because
for me like we make the video we put a
lot of work into it when I see it
reloaded on someone else's page when
they don't credit us and they're
profiting off of it in some form or
another
the only the only like satisfaction I
get when I see that is knowing that I
tricked people thinking robot has come
to life and it's fighting back and they
legit got freaked out and like I I takes
like it's so much satisfaction like I
love freaking people out like that
ah sit all day and someone hops in the
room like a feeling I've seen in had
they make an entire article clarifying
to people that know this video is fake
exactly it's okay yeah which makes me
like kind of feel a little bit better
that like if if we really tried to fake
people out right yeah like well I got
caught on day three maybe even day one
or two there was there was other site
saying it's fake
before CNN right yeah but what if we put
it out without the ending where we were
like selling shirts what if we put it
out without any context and maybe even
minus the shot words getting shot a face
like what people just be like this is
real is real is real or would there just
be still people would be like zoom in
you can clearly see here that it's not
real you have to take a few more steps
than that but like to just to just take
that and extrapolate it like if we were
we were a fake news organization we had
some agenda we were hired by somebody to
be like they put this out into you know
some backdoor alley like briefcase deal
like okay so you you put it on first of
all put it on Facebook and that's the
first place right and then Twitter and
Instagram and and do it from a profile
that create a few posts beforehand so
like the throw away profile yeah throw
away profile so that the platform thinks
that you're a legitimate profile and you
put something like this out there and I
mean yeah it goes back to like trying to
fool people wasn't our number one intent
it was like second or third in the list
of things were like number one was like
we're just trying to make a fun video
you know it's like something funny yeah
and two is like just try to maintain a
caliber of quality that we've always
tried to do which is just try to make it
look good and a side effect of that is
when it looks good enough it actually
looks real and you can start fooling
people but trying specifically to fool
people wasn't art I mean we have boss
town dynamics in the frame of every
single shot if we were actually trying
to fool people we would have just said
Boston right yeah
next time it'll calm slash door ya know
so it's been really interesting seeing
that blow up I mean like Wiz Khalifa saw
it Stephen Fry was straight-up fooled by
it is it's like I feel like anyone who
actually sees the video
and tries to figure out if it's fake or
not we'll be able to conclude pretty
easily and quickly that it's not a real
video yeah people were falling are the
ones who didn't put any effort into
discerning it like they're just like
they just see it on their Twitter
timeline or Facebook feed and they
scroll by and they just there's an
inherent trust that what you're seeing
as a video is real right that's the
craziest part cuz like people you know I
mean I do it too I'll just read a
headline and like oh that sucks
and I'll keep going you know I don't
read the full thing if I don't care that
much but I read the headline like ah
interesting you know now I know that
it's like I'm not gonna just judge the
book by its cover yeah and believe it
this conversation though is just leading
me to like what we have to do for the
next one I know I know I'm not I'm gonna
say what it is but we've talked about it
already dude are you saying you want to
try and make this as realistic you not
do that full proof is pieman because I'm
in firearms training indoor-outdoor oh
yeah every time I add it like a kill
house you know with like little walls a
nice ambience walks through the realize
someone tries to shoot targets like
three guns we can't even talk about like
this I know someone's gonna do it I know
we've already shot it that's right we
have everybody uploaded its person
[Laughter]
scheduled I want to hear about the sound
design process on this video because a
lot about the visual breakdown between
Clinton I but you did a lot of work on
sound design yes and I think that helps
fool people quite a bit because I
usually I tried to keep it like really
rich and like meaty I guess but still
keep it very bare-bones
because I started by doing a pass of
like funny sci-fi gizmo
gadget servo sounds and that helps like
accentuate things and bring a little bit
of like a emotion to it I guess because
because basically I would go through all
the key moments where it turns or does a
sharp movement or something like that
and and I put specific sounds in for
that so it's like constantly I guess
it's like ear ear candy you know what I
mean where you're just like you know and
it sounds really cool but that wasn't
what made it sound realistic and what I
did to make it sound realistic is I
literally just took parts that were
metallic
or like metal beams and rods things like
that and I went back to the loading
loading dock where we filmed it and just
got raw Foley of just like [ __ ] like
around like all the footsteps all that
stuff and I did it in the same exact
space that the scene was filmed yeah
that way it sounded exactly like it was
happening in front of us all the metal
clanking is you're mixing that sound
with the actual real sound that was
captured of us like shuffling around the
ground actually hitting exactly the back
with the kaki stick yeah so having all
that spatial like reverb and all that
stuff matched exactly makes it just very
convincing well I remember and at least
initially one of your first or second
passes of sound design was like
everything was basically there I felt it
was still a little too sci-fi because I
remembered there is some sound effects
that sounded like straight out of the
Transformers movies like that there's
there's a very unique like electrical
mechanical sound so you helped some of
that in there and it was like every time
I heard I was like this is just breaking
the illusion for me just sounds like
that little friggin mini robot from the
second produced after that in the final
upload you you did something differently
because I member listening to the final
thing to me like that's that stuff so
real that's great I didn't have a chance
to tell you that thank you yeah I key
with to making it sound like real in
that last stage like getting that fake
Transformers element was basically
taking all those produced sounds I had
and making them about half as loud as
everything else hadn't seen like each
time a box is dropped or smacked or the
robots hit or a footstep like the
impacts in the scene are are loud and
everything else like well if you had a
robot like that and it's in the scene
it's not gonna be just like you know
it's not gonna it's not gonna be that
loud so to speak so I made sure to keep
it as subtle as possible and let's just
like the footsteps I can make the
impacts actually hit reverberate plus
you also used my my drone for some of it
and then that was the little key yeah a
little startup beep there's a start a
beep when you plug in Oh is like Italy
yeah exactly so I kept that chopped it
up messed with the pitch so that it
didn't seem like it was the drones
sound India just did like little beepers
but we tried actually doing a thing
where it's like I actually would like
try to like move the motors around and
have it like do things in correlation
yeah the video but was it like there's a
dog barking or an airplane or something
like it didn't work one who's ended up
being like really subtle actually it
didn't have like the size it felt too
small I've been yeah the second part was
that the high-pitched whine of the
servos made the dog that was like above
us and like the loft above us start
barking so it's just this sound
I just couldn't clean it up my favorite
thing you did in the sound design Sam
was the end
went right before I kick right in the
nuts this sound you put it was like oh
yeah as the beeps
amazing have it yet you basically have
to make it talk by like doing musical
notes or something like that yeah that's
what I that's what I Meghan but you so
you mentioned like kicking me in the
nuts that was that was an interesting
solution that we had on set so initially
you're like alright I'm just gonna try
to kick you in the nuts but not actually
kick you I'm just gonna get really
really close you have to trust me and
like you did one test kick and I was
like hell no yeah I can't I can't handle
this I was like just eat you may have
been like maybe a foot away that there's
still too much just mess with my house
like side-by-side comparison videos that
you just you did the full kick with your
thigh but you didn't extend your knee
and then when you did the same thing to
to jake behind you you did a full-on
kick but he didn't fully extend your leg
because we can actually go through and
animate that leg to be extended cg knows
we have that control if we can do what
you have met him you did it and you did
it really quickly and easily - oh man
hey guys before we jump into our next
topic which is gonna be about deep fakes
that's right I wanted to tell you a
little bit about today's sponsor that's
right plug in everything plug in
everything has a bunch of awesome After
Effects plugins now we use them over
here they've also been used by companies
all over the world and
booting Google and Warner Brothers one
that they wanted us to tell you about
today is deep glow deep glow takes your
organic lighting from your footage and
it makes it way way way cooler it's for
After Effects so if you guys are looking
to do anything in that program consider
plug in everything there's a link in the
description below you can also go to
plug in everything dot-com and peruse
have a good time and I think after this
Ren is going to tell us about one called
coffee break which apparently can extend
your render times more on that later but
anyways a huge thanks to plug in
everything guys go and check them out
link in the description now back to the
next topic now - so did you talk about
the coffee break so they have a whole
list of plugins but there's this one
effect that is called extended coffee
break and mmin fact that you apply when
it comes to rendering that will actually
slow down your computer so instead of
like a five-minute render it'll take
half an hour so as its rendering you
know typically like oh my computer's
rendering I can't do anything about is
no game a smash yeah so it's like you
can actually now delay that if you want
to it's it's it's kind of messed up it's
shady and it's malicious frames and you
want to like extend that out so that you
can take an extended lunchbreak
is an effect that you can do you guys
were to get it plugging everything there
great yeah if you want to wants to buy
you a fast new computer just use that
plug-in every day thousand dollar
machine yeah if you want to
of corporates with 17 graphics gpgpu
thousand cores it's about that sharpness
inflection at the end that anger like
sharp anger and flex and your brothers
are still taking ours your special isit
keeps you in this office you to unique
we were talking about how the Boston
Dynamics video led to this realism that
we didn't think it would happen and and
just to link up our next topic deep
fakes depth faking the the the the 26
just I'm gonna bring in a couple world
events here okay call cultural zeitgeist
events the 2016 presidential election in
the United States of America was fraught
with all these stories and conditions of
fake news and then later it came out and
the Congressional Intelligence Committee
and multiple other sources of highest
authority have it have stated and
admitted look there were hundreds if not
thousands of stories introduced on
social media to affect public opinion
now with deep fakes right right now it's
2019 we have an election coming up next
year
okay there's already been some deep
faking recently with reeling with yeah
with Nancy Pelosi that wasn't a deep
fake though sorry wasn't a deep fake but
it was a I don't know the clip you're
talking about it was it was a thing
where somebody had basically made her
say something she didn't say and for
about eight hours or so which was a
story should watch the clip because I
thought I heard it was something did you
watch the clip no I did not I read about
it in an article after I would I might
either we watch it or I would maybe put
that one on the side to be totally
honest I think he just literally slowed
the video down that is just a is just
sort of a stepping stone to what I'm
really getting to which is like our deep
fakes going to be good enough next year
to actually affect like
people's opinion to fake people out I
think so I know you're gonna bring Nikko
in here to talk about more defects cuz
out of everyone here at the studio he's
the biggest pro on it but like he just
gave us this whole like hour-long
tutorial on how to do defects mhm and
now I know each one of us can do it like
it's not a hard skill to learn and
that's what's scary is that like right
it's low barrier to entry all it it's
like literally you just download this
free folder of files and you once you
learn how to like use which file it
suddenly you can now do deep fakes you
don't have to know how to do after if I
just have a computer kaien yes I so I
think deep fakes in the realm of like
personal attacks and like that kind of
scandal stuff like someone being you
know having affair things like okay so
first off like I think Trump has shown
us right now that no one cares anymore
about that like oh no Hillary Clinton
had enough I'm just saying like I'm not
Sara Lee saying like obviously they'll
be used for all kinds of things what I'm
saying like across the board there's so
many different situations you could use
them for to like create make up a story
you know not necessarily about someone I
mean yeah in particular but about but
about like a situation that's
representative of something going on
between yeah party politics like it
could be anything and that's what yeah
and I have a very strong feeling that
late next summer like once we get into
like August of 2020 that's when we'll
actually start seeing some of these
things pop up cuz all it takes is like
like you're saying just someone with our
skill set and malicious intent right
specifically focused on trying to fool
people we're gonna start seeing those
videos pop up over a long period of time
like if I think that if if we don't know
if it's real or not that's when it's the
issue you know because it's like we just
put out a bunch of stuff right now we as
a company know deep fake is realistic
enough to let me let me just and also I
just want to point another thing out
with the deep fake thing a deep fake
requires an actor and a set ran hand
like a cameraman like you have to stage
the scene ahead of time like the moon
landing or something like that
for example and then you have to bend
you skin deep i joking you know saying
like you need it's not just about like
it's that it's not as easy as you think
it's literally a production you have to
film scene
with a cures and and a visual effects
supervisor and stuff like that basically
- let me pose it and then to use and put
the face on there so it's like there's
so many fake things in the scene already
that it might be easy to point out that
I feel like it's still gonna be tough I
agree right now that's where it's at I
think obviously the technology is gonna
continue to get better but if you take
cameras you can you pull up this news
article just just just right there the
image that you have that Amir Putin
where there's there's two two of them
side by side technically there are
different kinds of deep fakes the 1d
fake we've been doing is basically
taking a performance and putting it on
someone else those are just changing
initial performance that's a something
that's what I'm mostly concerned about
is the ability to take the same person
and change their performance and change
the things that they say and I think
that's gonna be harder because I think
that's yeah that's like the performance
mapping thing where you are literally
yeah I feel like that's a whole no
technically that's not a deep fake right
but I feel like that 24 about saying
like what technically is or is not a
deep fake but I think we're very quickly
approaching de fake is now a term that
applies to any sort of manipulation of
faces yeah just a broad stroke it's a
deep fake if you try to fool someone
into thinking someone said as a color
here's my prediction here Sam's official
prediction check this out okay deep
fakes will be used in the next election
but they will not change people's minds
they will only embolden to their
pre-existing opinions so imagine there's
someone who likes to make fun of a
democratic or republican candidate
they'll they'll get an actor put a wig
on they'll do their little spoof though
deep fake the politicians face onto it
and then they'll send it right back to
their user base right who already
believes everything they're saying and
already believe it's it's it's all a
deep furthering them yeah it's like it's
like imagine we're doing a Hillary or
Trump mean let's say you you you're a
right-wing site and you make fun of
Hillary every single day deep fake her
on to another person's body send it back
out the audience same it's like it's not
gonna actually affect anyone's opinions
because the only people who are gonna
believe them or share these things are
gonna be the
people who already are in line with
that's still dangerous I would say it's
just as dangerous is what we already saw
where it's like it's this internet meme
culture that affects politics yeah
making fun of people yeah I don't know
if it's more dangerous I'm just saying
it's another tool in the malicious man's
toolbox yeah you know yeah yeah it could
be like a bunch of really tough right
wingers either going after like Bernie
or whatever going like oh look at how
much of an idiot Bernie is because he
said all these dumb things and you're
gonna have all bunch of lefties on the
other hand probably some big Trump
videos going oh look out dumb Trump is
he said and everyone's good it's the
world's could be exactly the same that
is what happened right before the 2016
election not with deep fakes but with
news yeah yeah yeah that's what I'm
saying it's just it's it's so they go
back to what Clint was saying just about
how you know you're scrolling a feed you
read an article you see something you
take those two seconds like people did
with the Boston Dynamics video you move
on mm-hmm at that point you know you're
not gonna fool everyone obviously but if
you fool if you're fool success rate is
25% that's you you know and in your
video got 50 million video it's like
that's that's real damage
so yeah that's true what what can be
done yeah now I'm thinking about it like
oh it's harmless in the sense that like
we're already [ __ ] thinking yeah
because in this world like we're in it's
like we're gonna be dealing with this
now for the rest of eternity I think
it's gonna require a couple of things on
the part of like the major media
platforms out there first of all I mean
there are companies that are already
making a software that specifically
identifies something that is or is not a
deep fake originated from all sort of
like markers that it should exist we
have classic videos what they Adobe
released some things on that I think I
think as this ramps up raw will so start
seeing more security ramped up but
before we change the topics that's super
cool I think you guys I don't want to
change topics that's what I want to say
change tone is a YouTube I want to see
Facebook I wanna see Twitter
bullet just like they scan this stuff
for
profanity or content like that they need
to scan for fake stuff and have they'll
have little markers in plan I was gonna
say yes Sam is the AI you know that the
AI technology that they're using
currently is not being used nearly to
the extent that it could be you know
well that's a smarter every month
because yeah that and also verified
profiles posting like to say say say the
algorithm and I know that this makes it
harder for individuals and this is where
the catch-22 comes in because am the the
algorithms should literally be only
promoting news and content to from
verified from verified channels yeah but
then at the same time it's very hard to
become a verified Channel if you're a
start out person start out creator start
out contributor so you know that's the
catch-22 but I feel like no matter what
the the talent will find its way through
you know like so I'm not as concerned
about that but like I think that's the
only way to you need you need like some
human manual review is say like okay
verify this channel manually then only
verified channels get bumped and then
that helps curb some of it but isn't
there a difference between a news
channel and an entertainment channel
because like what's to stop the this a
the algorithm from deciding between like
a deep fake on the news and a deep fake
for our Tom Cruise thing totally you
know so like where's the line on that
dude I think you just accidentally hit
on a really deep question because it's
like all news the state these days are
not they're innocent they're not news
networks they're entertainment channels
that's what they are these days yeah
that's a good question you're right
you're right sorry red no but moving on
sorry I'm trying to segue into getting
Niko in here because I'm in here then we
should bring once ones this conversation
sort of tones down then we should call
in Niko and have them come in here too
okay I think I think I think sounds good
to me I think one of the biggest my
biggest concerns are reading about the
people who have to do the manual reviews
at YouTube and Facebook and Twitter who
are taking down PTSD all the content
that we don't see oh god yeah and I've
been reading about this stuff and it is
it is the most horrifying thing in the
entire world eaten what do you mean
Facebook it's okay so first off these
people are the people at Facebook
anyways who have to review all the
content that is like child pornography
and like gore stuff like that do they
to combat that they've they open up
these giant offices of people who just
have to do the manual review of all
posts basically getting flagged and
reported and stuff like that make the
decisions whether to take it down or not
these are jobs that didn't exist years
ago but they do now and what from what
I'm reading it's like the working
conditions are terrible they're like
super super stressful and then on top of
all that basically have to watch child
porn and gore all day cool and so what
are we turning these people into it's
like what is going on I'm sure it is the
most horrifying thing in the world and
the faster we can get AI to take that
place yeah these people the perfect
solution for AI to take care of in the
future well I mean hopefully it can but
the problem is is is we have these
companies now that like are in this
position where they have to do this now
they they have to do that so yeah
there's no other way than by sending
hundreds of people into these little
cubicles to watch the world's worst
images for like eight hour eight to
twelve hours a day and it is like and
it's like you think drone operators in
Vegas have it bad dropping bombs and
stuff it's like no way man
like no Act that's probably way easier
to come home from than these guys at
Facebook so crazy right then you do like
we saw like 24 hours a day yeah and then
go to Facebook and then he just like
watch just like because that at like I
always I always think that like you know
probably cops have really hard jobs cuz
they deal with the worst of humanity on
a regular basis but this is is
deliberately dealing with the worst of
humanity yeah it's not just like oh this
person did this it came up now here's
all the other people that are normal
know here's here's intentionally we need
you
look at this yeah they have to watch
every single New Zealand shooter video
every single jihad beheading every
single like god knows what but anyways
I'm gonna stop talking about this okay
stressing me out
we're already doing this videos already
demonetised all right well should we
bring Nico in here to talk about his
take on deep Oaks yeah no I'd be really
curious to hear it so I will watch this
podcast later and three two one I'm Nico
what a cut demonize dynamics video that
led into like the sense of like how
things get photocopied and things get
taken out of context how that if with
done with malicious intent that can
create fake news and then now what's
upcoming a new a new thing that's sort
of similar what the possibilities are
with deep fakes and so we kind of went
through that now bringing you in we can
just start with like okay Nico you know
a lot more about deep fakes than a few
of us since you just did a whole thing
on it so tell us like what the process
was like maybe creatively and then like
we can get into the some some sort of
the bigger picture stuff after that
great okay cool
and three actually Dean I don't want you
to cut this part three two hi Dean one
hi Dean hi Nico you didn't live at Joe
Rogan the style of countdown I don't
know snip their word he leaves a new
dimension we don't we know incision Joe
don't say what happened Joseph rubbish
yeah we're talking about deep fakes
we're talking about the implications of
deep fakes but I fear I think first
before we get into that it would be cool
to hear from you like creatively what it
was like creating this first video that
we just put out and then sort of where
you think the technology is at right for
sure
so I'm something that most people
listening to this podcast have probably
seen on the court or crew channel and
most of our Instagram so we have this
deep take please subscribe guys Cruz
yeah yeah here I subscribed consider
doing that but um yeah so there's an
idea I've had for a long time they've
been wanting to do which is a hire a
celebrity impersonator and put a deep
faked face on them because it's one
thing to do effectively a mask put a
mask on somebody a face swab it's
another thing to have the voice and the
mannerisms in the costume and really the
voice at the end of the day that's the
hard part I know there's like some early
stages like voice synthesizing tools but
even then like you're not gonna have
nuance over performance you know like
the moment where even the impersonators
telling me to untuck my shirt like you
can't fake that yeah could you please
untuck your shirt yeah exactly
um not to mention you know being able to
play off each other's the same reason
you recorded Boston Dynamics with Clint
to actually in the shot you know I need
to have human beings acting off each
other yeah unless like you want zero
spontaneity in your scenes anyways so
yeah I had this idea to do this
celebrity impersonator deep fake for a
long time now two years ago or so is
when like the first deep fake stuff came
out like before that there's an academic
paper where somebody basically wrote you
know here's I can train an AI to
recognize facial patterns and if you've
ever seen like Google's deep dream or
other things like that you know
basically somebody boiled down like how
our how our visual processing works
which is you see you know black and
white you see color you see shapes you
see line you see form and then these
eventually get turned into symbols in
your brain and the symbols basically I
used for communication everything from
as simple as oh that's a phone or a cup
to everything that's complicated as oh
the car is moving towards me at this
speed you know that there's mythologist
coming down from shape recognition and
tonal recognition and that kind of stuff
and so if you step away and you abstract
it all you can do the same thing with
computer it can recognize tones and
shapes and forms and patterns
so here's a neural network and you can
kind of train that and so just like how
we can recognize faces people you know
basically these people out of university
kind of figured out the same thing and
that's when the first like deep fakes
were invented now these papers are
published the algorithms are published
and you know it's not like somebody's
just sitting there with a nice ready to
go program you know you just have an
algorithm now like somebody out there
has to sit down and do the work of
turning it into a program yeah and so
somebody actually did that back in the
day and that's where like the term deep
fakes comes from just from like this
early a soft
excuse-me software that people had made
I think it's just a guy the problem is
it was like the it was the roughest like
most basic program ever seen like you
had to have a very specific driver
version installed for your GPU you did
they have a very specific CUDA sit like
environment installed a very specific
visual basic environment stalled so like
basically you had to have your computer
frozen at that point in time to ever use
the program and so he didn't have that
specific GPU with that specific driver
in that specific visual but our you know
microsoft.net framework all installed in
that machine in a very specific way you
couldn't run the program so needless to
say very few people made deep fix and
just recently another guy I think his
name is Igor could be wrong I came out
with a program called deep face lab
which is using the same algorithms
people had worked on the algorithms
since then people like you know instead
of doing a half face which is from like
the bottom of the lips to the top of the
eyebrows and they do you know full face
now which goes all the way down to the
chin you know that was a new algorithm
for example lets me just basically made
it bigger than the other one yeah you
know yeah there's a little tweaks and
quirks and you know somebody's added you
know color matching and somebody else
matt added like edge blurring and you
know all these little things have been
added in to the program there's other
programs out there too I think it's one
called like face to face I guess deep
face is another one but deep face lab is
in my opinion currently the easiest to
use the most accessible and what it does
well is you don't need to have a very
specific driver and dotnet framework and
stuff and solid you can you can run that
on any nvidia card and even if you don't
have an nvidia card those versions you
can run
so the way all this technology works and
I guess the reason it needs your GPU is
it's basically you're going to feed your
computer a bunch of images of a human
face ideally of one human face and your
computer is then going to basically
break these apart in GPU and to like
tonal regions and shape regions like
that and just try to start understanding
the pattern not really like doesn't know
what a face is it's just going to learn
patterns and the nice thing is is let's
say so we did Tom Cruise you know I give
it five thousand pictures of Tom
Cruise's face that's how much you have
to give it because you need to smile you
need a frown you just smile from the
left smile from the right you know all
those different poses you can make with
your face need that from all angles so
you end up with a lot of images and you
feed it into the computer and the
computer starts looking at these images
trying to learn them it's kind of like
as if I were to look at Clint like just
look at him and then turn away and try
to draw a picture of him and at first
glance I might look at him back okay he
has two eyes one nose a mouth and be
there not a beard I look back at Clinton
like that was correct but I drew his
eyes too big I drew his nose the wrong
way I drew his mouth the wrong way or
someone go back and like refine this a
little bit okay let me look at Clint
again by drawing again okay these
changes i made made it closer to clint
and that's one of the key things here is
the computer needs to be able to take
these synthesized images compared to the
real thing and see how good it's doing
and so like with the Tom Cruise faces
you know look it takes one of the faces
it's been going through them and kind of
studying them and then tries to
replicate it and it looks at the
replicated face and it compares it to
the ground truth as it's called the
actual original face and it says well
how close are they the things I did
today does it does it match more but
it's just doing a basic difference
calculation right and if the answer is
yes the things you did made it match
more good keep doing those things if the
things you did make it match less stop
doing those things and it just does that
over and over and over and over hundreds
of thousand times users do like
computers ooh and little by little it
learns it learns what made it look more
accurate versus what made it look less
accurate so you do that for your actors
face the face you're gonna create the
mask out of you need to do a similar
thing for your destination face the face
are going to put the mask on just
because the computer is going to need to
understand okay the destination face
smiling and I know what the actor
smiling faces looking looking like now I
can recognize what the destination face
is looking like in terms of like oh it's
smiling or it's looking to the left I
know how to recreate that already so now
I can put the two together and generate
a new synthesized face and at the end
it's like it's not actually like that
crazy technology it's just an
application of a thing that computers
can do now these days which is Eva GPU
which can do billions of calculations
very quickly basic calculations but it
can do those basic calculations so if
you can break down a task into billions
of basic calculations well then you can
generate for example a face but you
could also do with other things you can
make a tree generator you can make a
cloud generator you can make a image
denoiser all these things kind of boil
down to the same thing which is pattern
recognition like for example someone did
a image D noise or where all you had to
do was taking it an image from a spot
with the same camera take one without
grain so like say do a long exposure at
night on the street and then do the same
picture with grain and then give that to
computer the computer looks at it goes
okay so this is what it looks like
without grain and this is what it looks
like with grain and I can use pattern
recognition to understand that this
grainy part should actually look like
this not grainy part then you can grab a
new grainy noisy picture from the same
camera via the computer and goes oh yeah
I I know it's supposed to look like
without grain now you mean it's like so
many plugins it's a little bit different
in that you're training at first like a
lot of plugins we use like Rd noises
that we use are basically looking at the
same frame or like a same spot of a
frame over a couple different points in
time to kind of figure out what it's
supposed to be but what we're getting
with AI now is that you're teaching the
computer it's learning I mean that's why
it's called artificial intelligence it's
not just a plug-and-play math function
it's an actual thing that changes based
on what it's learned but you know we
have to understand that learning to us
to a human being is a vastly more
complicated system of learning than it
is to a computer you know learning to a
computer is basic things like I'll do
this routine I'll measure the output it
has to be simple measureable outputs and
then you can have it lean one way or the
other
I actually took so when I went to
college I studied a little bit computer
science
and there's one class I really want to
take which was introduction to
artificial intelligence to take that
class you had to take two semesters of
calculus by that point I wasn't a
computer science major anymore as an art
major but I really wanted to take that
AI class so I took two semesters in
calculus so I could take that AI class
and it's actually really really useful
and really interesting at the end of the
semester you had to do a project we had
to make some sort of AI based thing some
people made like a image recognition
thing some guy made like a game where
you could play Mario just by like moving
your body you know it's all basic stuff
works like the computer learns that
you're facing it or you're leaning left
or you're leaning right you know basic
basic image functions and what we did is
we made made the game Mont kala
Mancala is kinda like an African version
of like chess or checkers basically you
have pockets with beads and then you're
trying to lift up the number of beads
and you place one in each pocket as you
move towards the end pocket and you want
to drop your last bead in the end pocket
to get a point where we're ads like the
most points the end of the game
basically wins the nice thing about
Mancala is that it's got the term here
but it's basically it's a game that has
very specific ranched functions or it's
like you can either move this or you can
move this and that leaves you with two
new states and then from those new
states you can do this or you can do
this and that leaves you with two more
new states so it's almost like a tree of
decisions it's not like suddenly halfway
through we like somebody drops a bomb
and the board blows up and all the
pieces get randomized you know it's a
very specific decision tree and chess is
the same way the problem with like
trying to teach a computer chess we're
like so the most basic form for an AI
for that the computer does pro it just
runs the decision trees deep soak in
it's like okay if I did this move what
happens okay if I did this what happens
if I did this move what happens okay
what if I did this move and then I did
this move afterwards what happens the
problem was like chess for example is
you have like forget how many pieces you
have it something like 24 pieces or
something like that so you know what's
24 times 24 times 24 times 24 like
suddenly it becomes an impossible number
to calculate like three moves into chess
for every piece it suddenly becomes
something like a computer can't handle
it's just too many decisions so you just
start shaping it where it's like look
you don't need to measure dumb decisions
hey does this decision to get you're
like Queen taken yeah don't continue
down that decision tree so you start
pruning your decision tree and these
things you start
I think the term for them is heuristics
I could be slightly wrong but you
basically start influencing it with kind
of shaped things so this mahn call the
game we made so I'm going with this is
that we had a grad student on our team
most most projects and in like school
you don't get lucky enough to have like
a grad student on your side but we had a
grad student on our side so we built a
basic mount caller game right where it's
like you run the decision tree as deep
as you can it was like you could go six
decisions in it's good and you can add
some things like Oh does this at the end
of these six decisions you may not be at
the end of you know you may not know who
wins or loses they're less points you
know so there's a way to measure a
decision is it good or is it not good do
you have more points or less points or
are you set up now to do a couple more
moves that will give you points like so
you can measure these things but you
don't quite know how to weight it right
like how important is it to be
strategically set up versus how
important is it to have more points and
so in this grad student being extra
smart and knowing way more about this
than any of us he sets up a an option
here where we had this game and he
hasn't run this game thousands of times
on all the computers in the computer
science building at night when no one's
using them on this and basically what he
did is he had it like a variable to each
one of these values like so you have
your do I end up with more points and he
had a variable to it right that would
weight it so the final thing would have
a weight of like how important is it
have more points how important is it be
more set up how important is it to have
like less pieces in these parts you know
it's like and he added just like an XYZ
variable to that and that would be
randomly shifted randomly weighted and
this is where the learning comes in
because the computers not learning with
it just does a decision tree that's
basic logic anybody can do that you can
do it with pen and paper the learning
comes in where the computer looks at and
goes like okay I'm gonna apply a value
of 5% two points at some point to have
points okay now I'm going to apply a
value of 10% I'm gonna play a value of
15% which one of those is now going to
give giving me the most victories Oh 5%
is okay now I've learned it's only 5%
important to consider points and that's
that's what this guy did is he basically
this is for all the variables for all
the different things that you could
possibly have in the program ran it on
thousands of computers formula honed in
the most optimized AI to play Mon call
it and so a curly
I think I still have it probably the
best a I'm on kala ever made
it can be any other boncala game we
could find like I went online I tried
any flash game we could find it could
beat everything because I don't think
anyone else has ever wasted as much time
but that's when I understood learning in
AI learning and that's not so much like
how we view the world is a much more
simple version of just repeating a task
and then measuring the outcome and
repeating the task and measuring out
competing the task measured an outcome
and you know that's kind of how it is
with deep fakes you're just learning
little patterns you're putting them down
and you're repeating the task and
measuring the outcome until you end up
with something that looks like your
ground truth so yeah it's it's crazy
it's like at one hand it's complicated
but in another hand it's so natural like
we're so familiar with this world that
like it's not complicated so how far are
we from being able to do this like with
the with have it be built into your OS
on your phone I think well that's a good
question because you have to train it
first yeah
now once you've trained it you could
have the model built in like silks and
right now we have a very good Tom Cruise
deep fake model and I can grab a video
view Jake and I get slapped Tom Cruise's
facing you and it would look pretty good
in about an hour versus like it took
about four or five days to train the
model on just in general but now that
it's trained I could put it on you
pretty quickly I would need to train it
on your face so it knows where your eyes
are and what your mouth looks like
because maybe it thinks your moustache
is your lips it doesn't know until it
practices on your face a little bit
right so theoretically it could just be
built into your phone or your OS but it
would need to be trained first I think
that kind of stuff actually happens with
Siri on your phone like Siri starts to
tune herself I'm pretty sure I could be
wrong but this is based on my experience
series starts to attune herself or
himself if you have it set to the guy to
your voice so I can be next to my wife
and I can say hey Siri and only my phone
turns on and hers doesn't realize it's
been trained over time little by little
to understand the difference in our
voices I mean we could try it right now
that's got to be the case because when
they first introduced Google home and
stuff and when they first introduced
they weren't that good no they weren't
remember when we first got the it would
like the the original goo
home yeah barely do anything and then
like a three months later we tried it
again and it was way more advanced em
hmm like wait a minute
that's crazy let me do a little test
here I have Sam's phone I have my phone
do you say any of your hey Siri turned
on mm-hmm okay hey Siri there it is my
phone turned on Sam's didn't Siri turned
on him I didn't
so Siri has actually been trained to
your voice a little by little it's just
happening in the background but don't
think that's something that happens on
launch though I thought you give it like
a little bit of a voiceprint right when
you maybe I think I'm think so
okay anytime you're doing it you're
giving it again try and sound like Sam
Clint say it will hold up both our
phones you say it let's see if either
referenced or not
I don't know H or no no you just say to
our phones I'll see if hey Siri
hey Siri that's probably just what's
worth might mean say we're saying two
feet away from you we're Christians my
room hey Siri hey Siri there goes
Christians again jakester hey Siri hey
Siri here's how I say I go I have a
downward inflection hey Siri
so try like that okay with that
inflection hey Siri hey Siri just got
mine
that's crazy you might be reading it
from an initial OS setup I never I never
did a pattern ization no no I assignment
yeah it's if you train you see I think
you basically just go hey Siri hey Siri
hey Siri like two or three times right
when you started up and it takes that as
the initial voice print probably I would
imagine that it builds off of that but
I'm okay I don't think it's automatic
that's crazy
there's definitely thurr way I think
it's pretty clear that there's
definitely deep learning yeah going on
it's great I love it yeah it's gonna be
very we were talking about how a perfect
application for stuff like that is these
these take down videos mm-hmm because
right now Sam was saying how there's
just so many people that are just
physically watching these things and how
draining it is to watch all this
horrible content I mean the better that
dpi gets that's that's a perfect
application for it right there yes just
I mean nope no nope did you watch the
look on valley yeah yeah i've seen every
episo-- do you remember that scene where
the guy makes the hot dog recognizer
yeah like recognize hot dog hot dog look
at all these pictures and yeah so I'm
pretty excited about deep picnic ecology
because at the same time people like act
like deep fakes like it's gonna change
the world politicians they're gonna like
be framed for things it's like that's
not quite how it works
that's the dramatic version the framed
for things the automatic version they're
like slightly tweaking people's thoughts
is the is that real that's what we were
talking about is yes like you it can be
used to embolden people's current
beliefs rather than introduce them to
new views I think I saw this video that
reaffirms everything I've already
believed about this person but it's fit
but it's fake I don't care that it is I
didn't take the time to figure that out
I'm one of the 25% of people who just
scrolled past it made my opinion and
then moved on and now it's reinforcing
my belief which is perpetuating me down
a road of
truth exactly and I think I think that's
the key here
actually I've never really thought of it
this way but I I think it something just
clicked for me I think it's that
incremental change that in that the
small nearly invisible incremental like
steering of one's thoughts yeah it's
it's almost not even it's like the grain
of sand thing or it's like Chinese water
torture version or droplet at a time ya
know one droplet is it's the end of the
world but yeah it's not like so for
example you know you have a deep fake of
President Trump saying we declare war on
North Korea it's like you know everyone
doesn't just take off in their planes
you know what I mean that's not that
dangerous to be honest like those huge
big ones but it's that idea of small
subtle changes you know the things it's
the same thing that like all social
networks right now we're facing when it
comes to like how they handle content
how they handle censorship how they
handle who gets demonetized or flagged
or not like that and like the whole
social culture surrounding it so I think
that's that's that's definitely the
weirdest scariest part because it's a
little it's kind of invisible still yeah
it's like this invisible critical mass
that it's sort of leading well eating to
the you're at your example of we declare
war right and then people from North
Korea see that and they're like why what
what and they're like maybe for a split
second they're gearing their minds to
like about time let's go and and then
they find out Ono's fake its fake and
they're like oh I was ready the thing is
defects don't let you do that like deep
faith I know I know but a mask I know
they just the idea of that though it's
like we're you in your mind you're ready
to go for a second but then you realize
it's faking like oh oh it's like yeah
it's like you say but for something
you're gonna buy a new car you save up
and then it's like I was ready to buy it
like oh but I'm not gonna buy a new car
came out but like I was ready to buy it
I might as well just do it I was ready
I'm just I'm seeing so many people use
deep fakes it's just a catch-all term
for like faking somebody else yeah right
I think it's it's just worth I like I'm
a technical guy I like to be specific I
wanted to get technical here deep fakes
are only when you take somebody else's
face basically generate a mask and put
it onto a new person so like for example
there's a
you're going around of Obama saying
basically they took a he was a key
appeal
I think it's Jordan Peele yeah but he
doesn't know about my impression one of
them it doesn't like an Obama impression
and they had Obama actually saying it
and I was like whoa look at this deep
fake like that's not a deep fake as
performance you're targeting if it was a
deep fake you'd either put Jordan peels
face on Obama or you put Obama's face on
Jordan Peele it was easy still be Jordan
peels balmy body or Obama's body was
what the other person's face so this is
not a deep fake that we're looking at
here because that's per that's this
called performance retargeting or
they're making basically doing a
two-dimensional morph so Obama
so yeah that's but this is this is
arguably going to be the thing that
emboldened people more to believe what
they currently believe even if it's
wrong then actual deep fakes yes and
this in so what's going on here is it's
similar thing that it's like pattern
recognition but you have this source of
Obama and he's an always have imposes
with all these different like mouth
shapes right and as Jordan peel is doing
his performance the computer is
basically going in fighting the little
snippets from Obama that matched that
it's like okay here he's smiling or here
his mouth as an au shape for example
mm-hmm it's taking that just that little
bit and using that little puzzle piece
for that little spot and like and okay
now his eyebrow he blinks here so it
goes to the video looks for where Obama
has blinked and some other thing uses
that as a little puzzle piece for that
little spot and it fakes are similar but
this is this is literally just taking
footage of Obama breaking it out into
little puzzle pieces of everything and
then reassembling those puzzle pieces
based on a new pattern which is
different than a deep fake which is
basically taking out somebody's face
effectively turning into puzzle pieces
but then putting that on top of a new
face after learning the structure of it
there's another little clip those like
these girls tearing up a gun gun range
target and then someone's just like comp
the Constitution on to it they're
tearing that apart so that's one of the
girls from the Florida shooting yeah so
but that's what I'm saying though like
how many people believed that that was
the thing instead of look
real I don't know how I did that but
this is just after-effects compositing
like this technology has been around for
20 years yeah it's like this is the
thing where it's like this idea of
incremental or it's like incremental
control and incremental like steering so
to speak where it's like you you already
are far left or far right and you see
something that supports your views and
you you just kind of get that one extra
bump in that direction it's not gonna
it's not like gonna completely go oh my
god president Trump laying around naked
no way
it's just never voting for him most
important things he could be teaching in
school now is critical thinking right
yeah exactly like this this is the thing
a captain disillusioned always talks
about I know it like he's like he
acknowledges that his videos are often
too like nitpicky sometimes on VFX but
he's really pointing out it's about
skepticism and critical thought and I'm
I'm honestly shocked and kind of
saddened by how many people thought the
Boston Dynamics video is real because it
does not take that much critical
thinking to figure out that it's not it
might look a hundred percent convincing
but the mole and some dude takes out a
gun and start shooting it in the room if
you still think it's fake by that time
and now we're sorry if you still think
it's real by the time after that scene
finishes and you still think it's real
you should really stop for a second and
think about how how willing you are just
take the world at face value because the
world what you see is you really not
what's going on and you need to be
skeptical with your things you need to
take time and apply critical thought
because anybody can say anything just
cuz it's written down doesn't mean it's
true
and if you're just seeing somebody
shooting a robot oh yeah that's real you
need to pause and think about the rest
of your life and just suppose we all
make that that all happens to us from
time to time you know it's maybe it's
like Saturday morning and you're
hungover
maybe it's like whatever you know like
you're maybe you're at a baseball game
maybe you're like at a party maybe you
know there's so many different
circumstances it's not like it's not
like every moment of every day you're
your most self-conscious like it's not
like you're your best self every time
you see a piece of information that's
true you know and so there is a there is
a responsibility I think on the part of
like the major social media platforms to
continue to improve the way that
information gets presented to people
right now
clearly it's there's some there's some
gaping holes
and if if if it can be improved through
like verified channels and the algorithm
learning more and over time I think
that's the only direction that we can go
in I agree and once again YouTube's
leading the way on that well I mean the
thing is is that you go to a small but
potentially a counterpoint to what you
said of like oh you see a guy shooting a
gun at a robot you should know this is
fake like yes it's ezel if well it's
it's also that is the way we designed
the video actually which was to
basically hold the viewers hands for
every step of the way
from when we start out trying to keep it
unassuming just a robot
next shot it's just a robot doing basic
Boston Dynamics things like basically
there's one extra smack with a hockey
stick but that's already in Boston
Dynamics videos and so each shot tries
to like do this it because like the
original idea was a the robot goes rogue
and like shot - and the whole video is
about it being Rogen oh we were like
wait a second
no like that should be like that the
cherry on top is is like fighting back
and going robe the rest of it completely
unassuming and building to that just
like with each piece perfectly
interlocking it's like okay you can hit
it with the boxy and hit with the chair
you're gonna hit it with a bottle but at
that point we've already smacked it with
like a half dozen totally average things
that when you break the bottle over it
like maybe yeah if you're if you are
paying attention that's the joke that is
the joke mm-hmm but at the same time for
us to keep it quote/unquote realistic
it's just that puzzle piece over that
building block so that by the time the
gun comes out you're like like I yeah
every step but there's a dove made sense
and so now a belief retention that
slowly goes down yeah over time yeah
ideally ideal like that at least that's
what the thought was when we wrote it
was like this is funny like this is
super funny the chair out of the corner
[Laughter]
with the chair yeah so I mean I'm yeah
so I there's the thing is that we were
kind of working against people's like I
guess suspension of disbelief
there's no not suspension of we're
working towards their suspension of this
below you know what I mean
when you can it break like we're saying
like yeah we're just trying not to go
like think like too loudly you know and
as we say fake we're just like thank you
like the frog in boiling water starts
off room-temperature terms of heat and
the Frog doesn't realize it's boiling
until it's too late which by the way
actually doesn't happen frogs no it's
hot jump out before they boil else have
anything else to say about this before
we close these matters before we adjourn
critical thinking there we go thinking I
think that's it that's a dope points a
good point a dope last poll I just say
if you guys are following the corridor
channel they're going to see an
exploration of this ideally in the next
month or so and all these other videos
were kind of like build up other things
they should teach in school
personal finance oh my god business and
taxes business how do I communicate
communications taxes personal finance do
you guys think they should teach gun
safety in school absolutely why not be
more aware like do ya everything just be
aware of everything why not I don't know
if you can like give them guns right
away but like start with like guns what
do you know and maybe just like just
basic guns they have a gun yeah I would
admit there's things that are far more
important than that and I wouldn't say
like hey let's pass legislation to do
that right over-over way more important
things but if you're talking about an an
ideal situation where you can teach
anything and everything and it's it
could be an elective mm-hmm like well I
see we're saying I think the thing is
not to interrupt but I think also like
when you look at all right we're looking
at a physical education we're looking at
math or history or all these variants of
that you know like math is the precursor
to learning to do
taxes still you know obviously there's
more advanced versions and reading and
English and things like that in physical
education being a precursor to learning
how to shoot guns I guess this more of a
machine shop kind of class that's more
that's better that's a better precursor
that in chemistry are no physics and
chemistry are precursors to gun safety
one of the greatest threats to the world
is fear and I think that absolutely Will
Smith
one of the greatest one of the greatest
problems just as Will Smith what I mean
we're friends now I've gone through
wills Instagram yesterday like oh well I
said I said wills and then I think I
like restarted Will Smith yeah do you
think his friends call him bill hey Bill
yeah billion billion but anyway what
you're saying is one of the greatest
threats is fear and I think that
absolutely applies in a number of
circumstances and I think firearms is
just another category in that yeah just
be aware of everything just you where
the other thing too is like we're this
wasn't like it this when we were in high
school but at this point now the
internet has changed in a way where
everybody's everybody's just constantly
regurgitating information because that's
how you yes how you're ranked on Google
like if you're are news articles new
we're gonna get views versus if it's old
so what happens is every just in this
churn of constantly rewriting stuff and
things aren't really researched anymore
it's just it's literally some 20 year
old kid intern grabs an old article
bangs out another one by adding some
extra words and then post it and that
happens here again later it happens a
year later happens you later and we're
at this point now where there's like
there's a constant churn of fluff online
where people are just constantly writing
stuff like I seem like when people post
about our videos for example they've
never called us they never did any
research they just like flesh out two or
three just fluff paragraphs before
before CNN 24-hour news didn't exist not
a single wasn't it was a concept it
wasn't like hey where can I constantly
find news information it's like well
before that people would go well there's
no new information to talk about so wait
until this time yeah that's true not a
single person not us and not a single
article that was written about the
Boston Dynamics video which there's a
couple dozen of them at this point
none of them reached out for any further
information or anything actually from
the source which is very interesting so
basically everything they said was
basically pure speculation they just
thought it was that Russian guy pure
speculation or an obvious like lot just
obvious facts that are then like there
are no word it out to sound more robust
I think appointed making that was like
there's no authority and information
anymore the only authority is your own
critical thinking Wow alright that's it
guys information but you're right it's
not the way that it used to be for sure
I mean we say there's a thorough
information you're right this summer
three but only if like only if the
actual sources and data are there like
right Spanish like the main Spanish news
networks thought the Boston Dynamics
video was real the universe other no not
not Mexican like Spain Spain like didn't
even bother to read boss town dynamics
in the corner that even catch that they
thought was a Boston the behind the
scenes was on the news they put they
posted the actual video and then you're
talking about in the middle the day
saying like Boston Dynamics is abusing
robots in their laboratory something
you're just sitting there like I got a
bang on a store you'll quick talk about
this and like drum up some anti robots
and that's those were like the guardians
and information twenty years ago and
that's what you're getting now is people
just it's just a YouTube channel at this
point people just churning out content
as fast as they can like it's funny
that's not funny that's hilarious
it's funny but it's also sad do you guys
want to have a positive takeaway from
this podcast it's that the word
heuristic means enabling a person to
discover or learn something for
themselves Hey
you are i FDIC are signing off
[Laughter]